es la vuelta al colegio en cuba pero
todavía no será presencial sin contar
algunas semanas aquí y allá la mayoría
de los alumnos no han estado en el aula
desde marzo de 2020 deben volver en
octubre o noviembre para acelerar el
regreso el gobierno ha lanzado una
campaña de vacunación de los niños
muchos de los cuales están ansiosos por
retomar sus vidas prepandémicas
fue una experiencia satisfactoria la
verdad es sentir ya que estando vacunado
podemos volver a tener vida social y
volver a tener las relaciones que
pedimos
hace dos años primero se vacunarán los
jóvenes de 12 a 18 años y después a
partir del 15 de octubre los niños de 2
a 11 años lo que convierte a cuba en el
primer país del mundo en ofrecer la
vacuna a niños de tan corta edad a los
jóvenes se les administrarán los sueros
locales apta la y soberana que fueron
aprobados para su uso de emergencia por
el regulador nacional de salud cubano
las autoridades no han dicho que las
inoculaciones sean obligatorias pero han
confirmado que las escuelas no abrirán
sus puertas hasta que todos los alumnos
hayan sido vacunados no va a quedar
desprotegido ningún paciente o sea
porque usted sea un paciente pediátrico
que ha que ha tenido la cob y no es que
no vaya a alcanzar su sistema sea su
vacunación inclusive se va a proteger
antes de empezar la escuela la medida
llega en medio de un fuerte aumento de
contagios y coronavirus en cuba desde el
inicio de la pandemia la isla ha
registrado más de 670.000 positivos y
5500 decesos por la enfermedad